il s'agit du dispositif 100 % contrôle
vous savez que la Guyane c'est la plaque
tourmente de l'acheminement de la drogue
vers vers l'Europe et je voyage
régulièrement et je suis souvent
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre en
fait qui effectuent ses contrôles mais
qui sont exténués parce que euh les
mules continuent en tout cas continuent
à tenter de passer il y en a qui passent
et il y en a qu'on attrape mais c'est
fatiguant et je pense que il y a y a une
solution qu'on propose nous c'est la
nécessité d'installer un scanner capable
de relever les objets ingérés comme un
chipole parce
que moi je vois pas le bout du rouleau
en fait il y a les 100 % contrôle les
policiers sont là la mission d'un
policier ben c'est assurer la la la
protection d'un citoyen or il se
retrouve là à l'aéroport alors souvent
il y a 50 personnes refoulées et puis y
a un autre problème monsieur le ministre
c'est que lorsque les personnes sont
refoulées on ne récupère pas le produit
ils repartent dans la nature avec leurs
produits il y a quatre gardes à vue pas
plus c'est pas possible il faut il faut
trouver une solution et la deuxième
question vous concerne parce que je
reste dans le domaine du transport
aérien alors j'ai été interpellé par un
groupe d'antiau guyanais par rapport à
la charé du billet en fait ma question
est simple elle est simple que
comptez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour permettre à nos compatriotes de
voyager avec un prix au kilomètres
acceptable parce que c'est compliqué
c'est cher c'est très très cher 1200 €
pour quelqu'un qui veut venir à Paris en
économie je trouve que c'est très cher
surtout lorsque c'est pour des raisons
médicales parce que elle n'arrive pas à
se soigner en Guyane ben il faut prendre
l'avion et il faut payer le billet la
Catrice pour les contrôles ça me permet
d'aborder la question de la sécurité je
pouvais pas êre sur tous les claviers
bon la guyaneement sujet de sécurité
vous le savez comme moi nous sommes en
éition au Sénat devant les
parlementaires on doit la vérité jamais
on a récupéré autant de cocaïne à
l'aéroport de Cayenne on est à près
d'une
tonne le ministre casenav que j'ai vu
hier midi m'a informé qu'il ira en Guane
en janvier j'essaierai de caler monagend
avec le sien j'entends que ce que nous
demandons au forces de l'ordre est
difficile mais si jamais on lâche la
bride à l'heure actuelle on ne tienera
plus rien il y a des accords de
coopération que l'on essaie de resserrer
avec les pays qui sont les pays de
passage vous savez tous mieux que moi
comment c'est les choses se passent avec
le Brésil en particulier où il y a toute
une immigration qui
vient de la Libye du Maroc on connaît
les grandes voies maintenant ça passe
par là et cet exercice est indispensable
vous parlez d'un scanner j'ai noté c'est
une très bonne idée naturellement j'en
parlerai avec Gérald d'armanin la
première chose dans le cadre de la
continuité
territoriale je porte la connaissance
pour tous les ultrmarins vous savez ça
par cœur mais pour ceux qui sont pas
ultr-marins euh je vous rappelle qu'il y
a un bel outil que connaît bien le
ministre dururel c'est la continuité
territoriale qui permet de prendre en
charge une partie des billets d'avion
pour 2024 nous augmentons de 23 millions
d'euros la dotation c'est qu'on passe de
70 à 93 millions d'euros deuxièmement
nous remontons le cent familial le cent
familial était de 12000 € pour la prise
en compte il est passé à 18000 € 50 %
d'augmentation ça veut dire que au
global 77 % 77 % de la population
ultramarine est éible
à cette aide nous sommes à moins de 3
semaines de Noël tous les étudiants de
première année du FAC pourront rentrer
et on a même anticipé la mesure la
sénatrice conc m'a beaucoup interpellé
là-dessus je crois ça pas été facile
puisque desg représenter je narrête pas
de les remercier là-dessus parce que
pour eu ça é un peu la révolution de
palais et on a mis 13 personnes en plus
aux effectifs 2024 pour aider sur ce
sujet là deuxème question vousavez pas
dit vousz pas parlé de la Corse donc moi
j'en parle on m' dit toujours l'IDE à la
cont territoriale par rapport à la Corse
est moins élevés c'est vrai mais vous
êtes des parlementaires donc vous avez
une vision globale des choses vous nvez
pas une vision restreinte si on regarde
globalement les choses faut regarder
aussi toutes les aides fiscales il y a 4
milliards d'aides fiscales pour les
territoire ultramarin il y a pas 4
milliardes d'aides fiscales en du
proportion du nombre d'habitant pour la
Corse donc moi si je fais la synthèse
d'aê par habitant sur l'ensemble des
territoires ultramarin par rapport à la
Corse c'est quand vous voulez j'ai fait
le calcul les territoires ultramarins
sont plutôt mieux aidés enfin sur le
prix du billet oui c'est trop cher quand
il y a pas de concurrence très cher avec
la guyan ce qui s'est passé cet été avec
Ker guyan qui a déposé le Buan ça ét
très compliqué la DSP d' d'urgence
refonctionne enfin on commence je crois
depuis la semaine dernière à avoir un
nouveau des liges intérieur qui décidé
de lancer avec Clément bon une étude
multicentrique pour qu'on voit comment
on génère de la concurrence et comment
on a un modèle économique vertueux que
enfin sur prix du kilomètres parcourus
ça peut être surprenant parce que c'est
Guillaume un collaborateur qui est à
côté de moi qui m'a dit alors j'ai
confiance mais toujours vérifie toujours
un petit peu il m'a dit vous savez
billets d'avion kilom parcourus ça le
fait sourire et mais ça fait partie un
peu d'un match par moment euh il me dit
vous savez c'est moins cher le kilomètre
parcouru par rapport au donc entre
l'hexagone et le territoire ultramarin
par rapport à d'autres kilomètres
d'avion parcouru c'est vrai il est moins
cher mais c'est trop cher c'est cher
1200 € c'est très cher je peux pas vous
dire autrement